Infinity War may feel like the climax to the
Marvel film universe, but it's only going
mark a new beginning.
There are a slew of Marvel flicks scheduled
to hit cinemas over the next few years.
As franchises continue to grow and expand
their rosters, it's getting harder to keep
track of everything that's happening.
Here's every movie Marvel has planned after
Infinity War, both within the MCU and across
other franchises.
Ant-Man and the Wasp
Marvel released the first Ant-Man and the
Wasp trailer a little earlier than expected,
dropping it the day after the Black Panther
premiere.
Director Peyton Reed announced that the film
had wrapped in November 2017, but because
of it comes out after Infinity War, fans assumed
that details would be scarce until after Thanos
shows up on Earth.
Judging from the trailer, however, it appears
that Ant-Man and the Wasp will take place
before the events of Infinity War.
The trailer opens with hero Scott Lang discussing
the aftermath of Civil War with partner-in-crime-stopping
Hope van Dyne, and there's no sign that Earth's
been shattered by Thanos and his Black Order.
Instead, the plot looks like it will center
around Lang going on the run with Hank Pym,
whose shrinking technology is now in high
demand by all manner of shady types.
The trailer also gives us our first glimpse
at Laurence Fishburne as Dr. Bill Foster,
a scientist who became known as Black Goliath
in Marvel comics after messing with the Pym
Particle and gaining powers.
There was no sign of Michelle Pfeiffer, however,
who will be appearing as Hank Pym's wife.
Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige told
fans that Pfeiffer was their "dream choice"
in the role of Janet van Dyne, the first owner
of the Wasp suit.
Captain Marvel
We've known for some time now that Brie Larson
will be Captain Marvel, but what we've all
been dying to find out is whether or not she'll
be showing up in Infinity War.
Turns out she definitely won't be.
Co-director Joe Russo put an end to the rumor
while speaking to ComicBook.com.
Of course, the fact that Russo specifically
denied her involvement in the third Avengers
flick seems to indicate that she will indeed
appear in Avengers 4, which will hit screens
after Captain Marvel in 2019.
As far as the rest of the casting is concerned,
Jude Law and Ben Mendelsohn have both agreed
to terms and will appearing as Mar-Vell and
Yon-Rogg, according to MovieWeb.
Lee Pace has also signed on to reprise his
role as Ronan the Accuser, despite having
exploded in Guardians of the Galaxy.
Captain Marvel enthusiasts still shouldn't
expect a rigidly faithful adaptation of the
source material.
Untitled Avengers: Infinity War sequel
Marvel originally wanted to shoot Avengers
3 and 4 together, though in the end that approach
proved too big an ask for the studio, given
the sheer size of the ensemble cast, many
of whom are in high demand elsewhere.
Chris Pratt, for example, has had to juggle
Marvel duties with the Jurassic World sequel.
The problem looks like it might get worse
going forward, as the Russos have revealed
that they're considering as many as 67 named
characters for inclusion in Infinity War.
Even Pepper Potts is rumored to be suiting
up for the big showdown with Thanos.
"Are you in The Avengers?
The next Avengers?"
"I... am I allowed to say?"
"I say you are!"
"Okay, I am, I am!"
The title of the sequel is being kept under
wraps at Marvel, because it's a spoiler for
Infinity War.
Joe Russo explained:
"It is certainly part of the concept of the
title is that it's advancing the narrative.
We're gonna sit on that until we feel the
time is right and when people have absorbed
the first movie enough."
Untitled Spider-Man: Homecoming sequel
After Marvel and Sony finally came to a mutually
beneficial arrangement regarding the use of
Spider-Man, it seemed unlikely that the wall
crawler would get just a single solo movie
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Tom Holland made his debut as Peter Parker
in 2016's Captain America: Civil War before
fronting his own standalone movie last summer,
and he confirmed that a sequel was in the
pipeline, saying:
"We've just finished Spider-Man [Homecoming]
and we're talking about the second one and
who the villain is going to be and where we're
going."
According to recent reports, Parker will be
facing off against a female enemy this time
out.
Marvel is apparently on the hunt for a European
actress in her 20s to play a "femme fatale"
type, and emerging details on principal photography
are leading many to assume that some of the
movie will be set in Europe, with a tentative
release date of July 2019.
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3
If Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 3 was ever
in doubt at Marvel Studios, the box office
numbers posted by the second film have made
certain that the team will be back for a third
round.
But Star-Lord might not be taking center stage
this time out.
James Gunn told USA Today that he's already
begun working on the screenplay for the third
film, which will apparently involve less Chris
Pratt and more Zoe Saldana — the director
said he's talked with the actress about having
Gamora take a more prominent role in the final
Guardians outing.
Casting news is already starting to trickle
through, with Gunn confirming that Elizabeth
Debicki will reprise her role as Ayesha, the
Golden High Priestess of the Sovereign.
There's nothing official in terms of release
date yet, although Gunn has hinted that we'll
be seeing Volume 3 sometime in 2020.
Ant-Man 3
Marvel Studios is clearly expecting the upcoming
Ant-Man sequel to go down well: A third installment
in the Paul Rudd-led franchise is already
in the pipeline, according to co-star Michael
Peña.
Speaking to IGN about his film 12 Strong,
Pena let slip that Ant-Man 3 is happening,
although he wasn't sure if he'd be needed
for it, saying:
"It's a whole different kind of club to be
in, the Marvel Universe.
I don't know if they'll use me for the third
movie, I still really don't know.
It's cool to make a little bit of a mark on
that Marvel Universe and it's kind of a cool
club, they run a really cool studio."
Black Widow
Scarlett Johansson made her debut as former
KGB spy Natasha Romanoff, aka Black Widow,
in 2010's Iron Man 2.
"I want one."
"No."
Eight years later, we're still waiting for
official confirmation of her solo movie.
Kevin Feige first hinted at a Black Widow
standalone feature in 2014 when he said that
her part in the MCU was "very big" and that
"The notion of exploring that even further
in her own film would be great."
He reiterated that Marvel was committed to
making the film happen in 2016, saying:
"I would say certainly the one, creatively
and emotionally, that we are most committing
to doing is Black Widow."
Another two years went without much news,
though a recent Variety exclusive claims that
the wheels are finally in motion on Black
Widow and that Marvel has hired Jac Schaeffer
to pen the script.
Johansson was consulted over the decision
to enlist Schaeffer, though Variety's sources
say the movie is still in early development
and doesn't have any plot details so far.
We do have one suggestion:
"The only thing missing in Black Widow's life…"
"Oops.
Such a klutz."
"...was love."
"Hey.
I'm Ultron."
Doctor Doom
The Fantastic Four don't have a particularly
great track record in movies, but a surprise
announcement at San Diego Comic Con 2017 gave
some new hope to fans.
Noah Hawley, the creator of the FX series
Legion, wrapped up his show's panel by revealing
that he was working with Fox to develop a
movie for the Fantastic Four's most iconic
villain, teasing it with two words:
"The first one is 'Doctor' and the second
one is 'Doom.'"
Since then, Fox has been bought out by Disney,
leaving question marks over some properties
in the early stages of development.
Hawley insists that the movie is still happening,
although even he's not sure when, telling
Collider:
"On some level, we're still looking at a period
of time — probably a year, at the least
— for this whole thing to go through.
[…] I've been waiting for the phone to ring
to see if anyone is gonna have an opinion."
"Doom needs no one."
Silver and Black
There's a lot of focus on Tom Hardy's Venom
at the moment, but Sony has also set the wheels
in motion on Silver and Black, another upcoming
feature based on the studio's Spider-Man portfolio.
Silver Sable has been both an ally and an
enemy to Spider-Man over the years, but has
never been portrayed on the big screen before.
Black Cat on the other hand, did pop up in
The Amazing Spider-Man 2.
Well, kind of: Rogue One star Felicity Jones
briefly appeared as a character called Felicia
Hardy, Black Cat's real name in the comics.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, Chris
Yost, who worked on Thor: Ragnarok, has been
hired to tidy up a script penned by Lisa Joy,
the co-creator of HBO's critically acclaimed
Westworld.
Gina Prince-Bythewood is slated to direct,
although the latest rumors suggest the film
was recently put on indefinite hold.
"Some things never change."
Laura
Daphne Keen definitely impressed as Wolverine's
offspring Laura in Logan, and director James
Mangold revealed that the success of Wonder
Woman has brought a solo outing for the character
closer to reality.
He said:
"That film only solidifies more for studios
that there's less to fear with a female protagonist.
The more that keeps getting hit home, that
ends up giving me more space turning around
and going, 'Well, here we are with a female
protagonist.
That's incredible.
And what are we going to do with her?'
And that's where we are with that right now,
dreaming."
X-Men: Dark Phoenix
This direct follow-up to 2016's X-Men: Apocalypse
will bring back all the big-hitters from the
previous movie, with the addition of Jessica
Chastain as one of the film's villains.
Dark Phoenix will mark the directorial debut
of Simon Kinberg, although Kinberg has been
working on the X-Men films as a writer and
producer since 2006's The Last Stand, a botched
attempt at adapting the classic Dark Phoenix
Saga.
Kinberg confirmed that the film will follow
the franchise's decade-skipping trend, jumping
forward from the '80s-set Apocalypse to a
'90s setting.
It's scheduled to open November 2018.
Multiple Man
After directing Dark Phoenix, Simon Kinberg
will return to the producer's chair to oversee
yet another spinoff in Fox's X-Men franchise.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, Kinberg
is in negotiations with James Franco over
the lead role in a planned adaptation of Multiple
Man, a mutant with the power to create and
control clones of himself.
"Cripes."
While casual viewers probably won't recall
the name James Madrox, the character has actually
popped up in Fox's X-Men movies before.
He was portrayed by Eric Dane in 2006's X-Men:
The Last Stand, appearing as one of the mutants
recruited by Magneto.
Gambit
In development since 2014, Gambit seemed like
a sure thing when an X-Men producer confirmed
that Channing Tatum would play the card-tossing
mutant.
After several directors left the film, Gore
Verbinski jumped into the hot seat and was
eyeing a Valentine's Day 2019 release, although
The Hollywood Reporter later confirmed that
Verbinski has become the third director to
walk, leaving the seemingly cursed project
in limbo once more.
Fox has reacted by pushing the release date
to summer 2019, giving itself some breathing
room just in case they can't find a replacement.
Tatum remains attached, along with Lizzy Caplan,
who has been cast as the film's female lead.
Hopefully, Tatum keeps Gambit's Cajun accent.
"Pop go dah weasel."
Venom
Sony had been discussing a Venom movie for
over a decade when the studio finally confirmed
that the symbiote's solo adventure was going
ahead.
Tom Hardy is playing Eddie Brock, the first
character to take on the Venom moniker in
Marvel comics.
Despite being a fan favorite, the anti-hero
has only been portrayed in film once, when
Topher Grace donned the black for Spider-Man
3.
"Oh yeah, I know all about you."
Hardy is set to play a central role in what's
being dubbed the Sony Marvel Universe, and
director Ruben Fleischer revealed that the
film would follow the Planet of the Symbiotes
and Lethal Protector comic arcs.
Venom is slated for an October 2017 release.
Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse
African-Latino Spider-Man Miles Morales was
only supposed to be around for four years
in the pages of Marvel's comics as part of
the Ultimate Marvel imprint.
But this version of Spidey proved so popular
that Marvel decided to merge him into the
main line, and now he'll be the focus of a
feature-length animated movie.
At present, the film is scheduled to be released
on December 21st, 2018.
New Mutants
Marvel fans everywhere got a thrill from the
trailer for New Mutants.
The horror-inspired X-Men spinoff is being
helmed by young filmmaker Josh Boone, who
took it upon himself personally to convince
Fox it was a property worth adapting.
He and co-writer Knate Gwaltney put together
their own New Mutants comic book based on
stories they wanted to adapt for Fox, and
the studio loved it.
Boone explained:
"It walked them through a trilogy of New Mutant
films that would build on each other.
[It] took all the images we had loved from
the series and strung them together to show
them the movie we wanted to do."
Even then, it took a long time for the film
to happen.
"We spent a couple years writing the script
before I went and shot the movie.
[...] We worked on it for two or three years,
I think."
Shooting has already wrapped on the film,
and fans can expect to see it in theaters
in August 2019.
Deadpool 2
After 2016's Deadpool unexpectedly became
the highest-grossing film in the X-Men franchise,
keeping the creative team together for the
follow-up seemed essential.
That wasn't to be the case — director Tim
Miller soon departed the project, and David
Leitch of John Wick fame has since stepped
up to direct.
Josh Brolin will also be welcomed into the
fold as the time-traveler Cable.
Fox dedicated an entire trailer to introducing
the character, emphasizing his war-torn past.
The trailers also confirmed that Brianna Hildebrand
would be returning as Negasonic Teenage Warhead
and that T.J. Miller would reprise his role
as Weasel, along with a whole new cast of
mutants.
Deadpool 2 arrives on May 18th.
X-Force
Another project promised by Fox is X-Force,
a black ops team of Marvel mutants far more
brutal than the X-Men.
The film will revolve around Deadpool and
Cable.
"X-Force!"
"Isn't that a little derivative?"
"You're absolutely right."
A report picked up by MovieWeb states that
X-Force will begin filming in October 2018,
with Drew Goddard attached to direct.
According to a recent Discussing Film exclusive,
the green light remains firmly on for Goddard's
X-Force, regardless of the Disney takeover.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!